haben sie schon einmal einen cyborg
persönlich getroffen leben sie
vielleicht gar mit einem zusammen was
lange ins reich des science fiction
gehörte wird dann immer
selbstverständlicher teil unserer
lebenswelt die zunehmende verschmelzung
von mensch und maschine von leib und
prothese auch unser heutiger gast der
sozialpsychologe berthold maier
verkörpert als träger einer hightech
unter als prothese diese entwicklung im
rahmen der sft woche mensch maschine
will ich mit ihm dazu über die geradezu
utopischen möglichkeiten aber auch
ernsten ethischen herausforderungen
dieser entwicklung sprechen
herzlich willkommen ich habe ja danke
herr meier sie sind professor für
organisationspsychologie sie forschen
zum thema stereotyp und diversität am
arbeitsplatz das heißt wie vorurteile
und gruppieren und unser urteil von
menschen verstellen re figurieren
bewertungen möglich und unmöglich machen
und sie sind 19 07 19 77 auf die welt
gekommen aufgrund einer fehlbildung
einer sogenannten des millionen linken
unterarm
wann haben sie zum ersten mal für sich
selbst wahrgenommen ich bin anders als
die andern ich bin behindert
wenn ich es an einem moment festmachen
müssen war das wahrscheinlich der tag
der einschulung in der grundschule
ich trug damals eine prothese wo so
einem metallhaken die linke hand ersetzt
hat und als wir alle in der klasse
angekommen waren stellte sich meine
damalige klassenlehrerin hinter mich und
ich mir so die hände auf die schulter
und stellte mich nochmal so extra der
klasse vorne das ist berti und und sie
hat dann irgendwas über meine
behinderung erklärt damit dass alle
irgendwie verstehen und was sie genommen
sagte weiss ich nicht mehr aber das war
so einer dieser momente wo mir also der
sehr sehr deutlich wurde
hat sich schon sehr anders als meine
mitschüler das paar sich einen eindruck
hat sich über die jugend dann auch
verstärkte würden sie sagen da besteht
eine innere verbindung zwischen ihrem
jetzigen forschungsgebiet und der
entscheidung soziologe zu werden und
dieser wahrnehmung von sich selbst als
anders es war keine bewusste
entscheidung ich habe erst angefangen
informatik zu studieren
es sollte alles ganz anders verlaufen
aber es stimmt schon ein anderer
sozialpsychologe hat mal gesagt research
ist immer auch ein bisschen research und
vielleicht war es unter bewusst so auch
die eigene erfahrung von andersartigkeit
die schlussendlich dazu geführt hat dass
ich mich jetzt vor allem damit
auseinandersetzen was passiert wenn
menschen die zueinander anders sind vor
allem am arbeitsplatz aufeinander
treffen und miteinander umgehen gerade
wenn sie kooperieren müssen also das ist
das thema diversität und auch inklusion
würden sie denn sagen dass er eine
maßnahme wie die lehrerin dieses
herausstellen da ist der berta des
bisschen anders ist das was produktiv
ist in ihrer sicht oder etwas
unproduktives für den sozialen
zusammenhalt
ich glaube das kann man ganz schlecht
allgemein sagen es kommt sehr darauf an
wie das gesagt wird und wie das ankommt
menschen in gruppen einzuteilen und
diese gruppeneinteilung immer wieder
hervorzuheben ist problematisch
unterschiede herauszustellen ist in der
regel für eine kooperative
zusammenarbeit problematisch aber man
kann ja auch unterschiede als etwas ganz
natürliches darstellen wir sind alle
unterschiedlich aber wir sind auch
irgendwie alle gleichen es ist dieser
punkt dass das unterschiedlichkeit ja
normal ist keiner von uns ist gleich der
genau dem anderen und wenn man es
schafft dass in einem solchen diskurse
einzubetten so wir sind alle irgendwie
anders
aber wir gehören alle zusammen dann muss
das nicht groß problematisch sein kann
ich eben nicht mehr genau daran erinnern
wie sie das damals gemacht
sie sind seit dem dritten lebensmonat
träger einer prothese und wenn ich es
richtig verstehe hatten diese prothesen
in ihrem leben business später wachsen
alter mehr kosmetische funktion als
funktionale ist das richtig nicht ganz
also ich hab ganz früh mit drei monaten
so eine prothese bekommen das nannte man
damals einfach deutschland damit konnte
man gar nichts machen ein stück holz
einfach nur um das gefühl das
körpergefühl zu kriegen dass da noch was
sein könnte wo nicht ist und ich meinen
danach die erste funktionale prothese
war diese erwähnte zangl das war schon
funktional im sinne von da gab es dann
so gut ist wie licht und dann hier so
irgendwie hinter marlies und unter der
schulter drunter durch und wenn man die
schulter dann anspannte dann ging so die
zange auf ihn baut und sucht bei der
fahrer bremsen grunde genommen
da waren also federn wenn man also
wieder denke genau das war sicherlich so
zu toben irgendwie auf dem spielplatz
und so war das glaube ich auch ganz
angemessen ich hab das ding dann aber
lange nicht getragen also bis ich zwölf
jahre alt war habe ich eigentlich gar
keine prothese getragen und ich habe
dann angefangen mich sehr bei den
fraktionen zu engagieren
und da war das dann doch ein bisschen
blöd nur mit einer hand und dann habe
ich aber wieder angefangen den den haken
zu tragen und es war so rees kempten
vorher machen selten und so war das
schon auch sehr angewiesen
aber gerade so wenn dann so die pubertät
kommt und dann auch so die eigene
selbstwahrnehmung steigt und es ist eben
auch so in richtung sexualität geht dann
war das schon auch ein dicker brocken
und dann habe ich halt geguckt ob das
nicht was gibt was kommt ist kosmetisch
ansprechender ist und da bin ich dann zu
meiner ersten elektrischen prothese
gekommen ganz simples teil dass nur so
eine bewegung kann auf zypern keine
zwischen daumen und zeigefinger greifen
aber die hatte dann ebenso ein
hautfarbenen gummihandschuhen sagen also
ein bisschen das man auf den ersten
blick vielleicht das gar nicht sah
bei dunkelheit auf den ersten blick
vielleicht dann passiert etwas ich
glaube im jahr 2009 dass ihr leben
wirklich verändert hat denn sie bekamen
eine bionische prothesen in einem fein
ein weiter entwickeltes modell tragen
sie jetzt erzählen sie doch mal etwas
was das bedeutet hat für sie so eine
hightech prothese zu tragen nicht nur im
sinne der funktionalität sondern auch in
der wahrnehmung für sie als menschen
also der unmittelbare nutzen den man von
einer prothese hat bei der sich
tatsächlich alle finger bewegen mehr
oder weniger auch unabhängig von einer
mit dem man komplexe dinge machen kann
ist natürlich erstmal mit funktionaler
nutzen
man kann einfach mehr sachen besser im
alltag ja spielserie zu binden
autofahren kochen so die kleinigkeiten
die das leben lebenswert machen beide
nach solchen prothese ist es aber sie
sind auch ein sie sieht auch anders aus
und ist erst mal finde ich so vom
ästhetischen standpunkt ist das den
ingenieuren sehr gut gelungen die
prothesen die ich vorher trug verströmt
den charme eines sanitätshauses der 70er
jahre
und das tut diese hand halt gar nicht
und dessen ist ja die hersteller soll
man sich auch bewusst und bietet die
hand deswegen ganz bewusst auch mit
diesem transparenten überzug an der es
nicht versucht zu verstecken und ich
habe mich von anfang an bewusst dafür
entschieden weil ich war es einfach leid
ich war es einfach leid dass man immer
so tut als wäre der hand obwohl da
keiner ist das sendet auch ein komisches
signal nach außen nämlich dass man ganz
genau eine verschiebung hört man dass
man versucht die eigene behinderung auch
zu verstecken und die reaktion die man
dadurch erntet ist häufig mitleid oder
zumindest verunsicherung so wenn sie
jetzt aber so eine hand tragen die
erstens technologischen fortschritt
ausstrahlt und auch gar keine mühe macht
das zu kaschieren was es ist
reagieren die leute ganz anders nämlich
nicht mehr mitleidig sondern mit
interesse gerade kinder
aber wenn die leute anders anfangen auf
ihre behinderung zu reagieren nämlich
nicht mehr mit so einer impliziten
abwertung sondern eher auf augenhöhe
wird so einen ehrlichen interesse
dann ändert sich auch das eigene
verhältnis zur eigenen behinderung auch
es gibt eine rückkopplung von fremd- und
selbstwahrnehmung sich selbst sprechen
und verändert sich und es gibt einem
eine menge mehr selbstbewusstsein und
ich finde das auch nicht unproblematisch
und ich wünschte es wäre nicht so denn
man muss sich ja schon darüber im klaren
sein ich mache dadurch auch ein stück
meines selbstwert ist abhängig von einem
aufwändigen auch sehr teuren stück
technik ja jetzt muss man dazu sagen sie
sind vertraglich gebunden an diese firma
einnimmt man kann sagen die werden
gesponsert wie ein sportler von einer
sportler für immer
gesponsert wird und diese entscheidung
das ist für mich ganz interessant zu
hören der hand ein sagen wir offensiv
futuristisches ein zukünftiges design zu
geben
das bringt sie aus der faschingsfeier in
einer art offensiven umgang mit ihr
passiert etwas was interessant dass hier
passiert etwas was die zukunft selbst
repräsentiert ist das eine beschreibung
die ihn plausibel erscheint also ich
persönlich denke jetzt nicht so weit
dass ich sage ich versuche dadurch
irgendwie so die zukunft zu
repräsentieren für mich fühlt es sich
einfach authentischer an dass ich sage
so wie es jetzt aussieht repräsentiert
ist eher was ich bin nämlich ein mensch
mit einer körperbehinderung der ein
technisches hilfsmittel verwendet um
einige der nachteile die dadurch
entstehen auszugleichen nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
aber natürlich stellen sich aufgrund der
rasanten entwicklungen die prothesen
haben sich in den letzten sechs sieben
jahren unglaublich weiterentwickelt im
vergleich zu dessen nachfolger stellt
sich natürlich auch ein paar
interessante und neue fragen mit denen
ich mich natürlich dann auch gerne
beschäftigen bevor wir zu sagen zu den
fragen die die ganz auch ethisch
relevanten unsere ganze lebenswerk
betreffen werden kommen sollten wir
vielleicht die die leistungsfähigkeit
die in der tat erstaunlich
leistungsfähigkeit dieser prothese mal
am objekt zeigen ich habe hier was
vorbereitet wie in einer kochshow gleich
haben sie sagt zum beispiel schuhe
binden war lange ein problem ja und das
ist jetzt mit dieser prothese möglich
wollen sie vielleicht kurz sagen wie das
geht und auch wie die prothese genau
funktioniert es heißt wie sie bewusst
vielleicht willentlich auch muskulär
steuern
da liegen zwei elektroden auf dem arm
die messen das muskel signal von dem
muskel der eigentlich dafür zuständig
wäre
das linke handgelenk an zuwinken
eigentlich so diese bewegung zu machen
wenn sie aber keine handhabe dann ist
dieser muskel nutzlos und sie können ihn
als interface schnittstelle verwenden um
technologie anzusteuern das heißt die
hand hört dass ein einziger muskel
letztlich auf der seite weil er in einen
muskel und die hand geht eigentlich nur
auf uns zu aber das auf sehr
intelligente art und weise
da kann ich ja vielleicht ein bisschen
was zu erzählen aber erst mal alleine
dadurch dass die hand sich so adaptiv
schließen kann und einen sehr guten grip
hat kann man sachen also auch sowas
rutschiges wie schnürsenkel total buch
festhalten heißt sie passt sich der
umwelt die sie fast in gewisser weise an
genau die hand ist mit einer druck
sensorik ausgestattet
das bedeutet die finger wenn ich einen
schließen signal gebe spüren nennen ging
ein objekt kommen und hören dann auf
sich zu bewegen und wenn sie nicht
spüren dass sie gegen ein objekt konnte
wegen sie sich weiter ein gutes beispiel
dafür ist zum beispiel so was zur linde
schloss ihn wie ein wasserglas ja also
ich weiß nicht ob sie das sehen sie die
drei finger
die merken dass sie gegen das glas
kommen und hören auf sich zu bewegen und
dieser kleine finger und er dreht sich
halt jetzt unser das glas das hat den
enormen vorteil selbst wenn ich mal
versehentlich einen öffnungs im kurzen
öffnungskurs gehört dann fällt das glas
nicht runter weil da ist immer noch der
kleine finger krumm klar das ist ein
riesen unterschied zur technologie
vorher die nur zwischen daumen und
zeigefinger greifen konnte selbst wenn
sie die hand nur einen millimeter
geöffnet haben ist ihnen alles runter
gefallen
das passiert ihnen zwei mal und dann
benutzen hat eine starke verunsicherung
eingemeindungen und wenn wir jetzt zum
beispiel wenn du jetzt einander die hand
geben
man erkennt die hand den widerstand in
meiner hand biete genau aber sie fühlen
wie man im landläufigen sinne sagt gar
nichts ich fühle nichts ich sage der
hand nur sie schließt sich sie soll sich
schließen
die hand merkt dass sie gegen einen
widerstand kommt der hand und hört auf
sich zu bewegen obwohl ich das signal
noch gäbe her so damit ich nichts kaputt
mache und wie ist das wenn ich jetzt
hier raus lehnt also ja ich kann jetzt
den druck noch mal erhöhen und greift
die hand ein bisschen mehr zu ich habe
keine superkräfte damit ja aber man hat
einen festen händedruck faszinierend und
um das mal zu sagen es gibt ein muskel
der eine recht einfache operation stehen
könnten und die differenzierung läuft
dann über die technik ganz genau
ganz genau also die grundbewegungen ist
das ist das öffnen und schliessen aber
die hand kann 24 verschiedene gesten wie
das genannt wird in denen sie diese
öffnung und schließung durchführen
können
und aus diesen 24 suchen sie sich ein
paar aus ihre favoriten wenn sie so
wollen
und die können sie dann mit ganz
bestimmten muskeln impulsen zu offen und
sie suchen die bedarfs- gemäss aus
einfach welche tätigkeiten welche lebens
kontexte sie zu bewältigen genau also
man man findet dann um man raus was
gutes nur zum beispiel gibt es ihnen wie
diesen griff wo sich nur der daumen
bewegt und das ist es gibt also eine
schmale silhouette was wichtig ist um
eine jacke drüber zu zählen ja oder
machen sie haben die möglichkeit so was
ihnen klipp griff zu machen wie das was
ich eben schon demonstriert habe der nur
dafür da ist um das glas zu halten nicht
bewusst ihr das nochmal ein bisschen
meine aufregung hatten sie mal kurz aber
jetzt haben wir im moment
ich nehme jetzt auch war das ist ein
bisschen wie ein instrument spielen
lernen das heißt es braucht tägliche
übung oder zumindest viel übung ganz
genau also am anfang ist es noch relativ
kompliziert dann wird es wird es sehr
intuitiv die verschiedenen lesen die man
damit machen kann also zum beispiel sie
lernen dann irgendwann dass sie wie sie
das machen dass sie nur den daumen so
positionieren ja oder sie lernen dann
die gesten dafür die sie ausführen
müssen um zum beispiel so nur den
zeigefinger auszustrecken viele tippen
und extrem praktisch ist jetzt viel an
der tastatur hier und da benutze ich das
also control steuerung als unsympathisch
aber jetzt vielleicht wenn wir noch
diesen schritt weiter gehen weil das es
besonders fasziniert sie haben ein
iphone hat eine app mit der sie dann
diese 24 verschiedenen positionen
aktivieren können
die app ist im wesentlichen dazu da die
hand zu konfigurieren
das heißt also diese favoriten
festzulegen ja aber man kann tatsächlich
diese hand nicht nur über die app
konfigurieren
sondern man kann sie tatsächlich auch
ansteuern
es gibt dann in der app eine übersicht
über alle 24 griff muster die die hand
kann und man kann hier tatsächlich in
der app wenn man auf einen griff tippt
macht die hand dass ich kann ihnen das
jetzt mal geben das heißt ich kann jetzt
ihre hand bewegen genau jetzt eine der
gesten aus wie ich mach jetzt schnelles
daumen parken hast dass das ist dann
diese bewegung ich kann jetzt immer auch
den daumen bewegen aber sie haben jetzt
die geste aktiviert
sind sie jetzt in ihre muskeln eine
veränderung also haben sie ihren
phänomenalen anderes gefühl
nein das ist alles das gleiche ich
drücke jetzt nochmal zum beispiel drei
finger griff mit fixiertem daumen so da
bewegen sich jetzt halt nur diese drei
vermissten weise hier diese beiden
greifen halt in opposition zu dem
fixierten daumen dass ohne für filigrane
und was sie sagt man das dann vielleicht
am nächsten beispiel sehen
geschwindigkeit ist immer noch eine
herausforderung weil sie haben auch
gesagt drücken sie nicht zu schnell
drauf ich drücke es vielleicht nochmal
auf eine weitere bewegung die jetzt sich
hier nicht da sehen sie ist eine weitere
aber ist dauert eine weile also dauert 3
4 sekunden also die hand bewegt sich
langsamer als eine natürliche und so
natürlich ist ein großes wunder werk was
geschwindigkeit und komplexität angeht
so weit sind wir noch nicht man könnte
das hier zum beispiel sachen sie an so
einem rubik würfel entwickeln der song
höre motorischen fähigkeiten eben aber
auch diese geschwindigkeit sehr große
forderung stellt wollten sie dass man
eigentlich auch auf wo eine kombianlage
herausforderung steht ein schwieriger
und man konnte also gerade dann wenn es
irgendwie darum geht es also man kann
das schon noch einigermaßen manipulieren
wie sie sehen also dass ich jetzt hier
groß irgendeine lösung favorisieren
würde aber sie sehen es ist halt doch
noch ein tick langsamer als mit einer
natürlichen hand also rubik's meister
werde ich damit nicht es geht schon ganz
gut so ja mir aber ja da gibt es also
noch kennt wird sie auch sagen
geschwindigkeit ist jetzt was sagt
alltags verwendung an geht für sie ein
haupt erfordernissen haupt er wäre noch
ein haupt fortschritt möglich also mehr
geschwindigkeit wäre schon besser aber
für mich wäre der größte nutzen wenn die
ansteuerung filigraner wäre denn alles
was ich ja im grunde aber momentan die
apotheke sagen kann ist auf und zu und
das auf ganz viele unterschiedliche
arten und weisen ja und ich kann dann
die gesten verändern mit der die in der
sie dann auf und zu geht das kann ich
über muskel steuerung machen das kann
ich über das smartphone machen ich kann
das sogar mit einer smart watch machen
und es gibt noch viele andere möglich
aber man kann halt nicht filigran
präzise in einzelnen finger ansteuern
sie können damit nicht klavier spielen
oder karnickel drei sind ja genommen so
was geht hat damit nicht und das ist
eine große herausforderung denn
theoretisch könnte die hand das ja weil
jeder finger hat seinen eigenen
elektromotor der daumen sogar zwei das
heißt sie sind technisch voneinander
unabhängig bewegbar die herausforderung
nur wo sollen die informationen herum
die steuerungs impulse um diese motoren
unabhängig voneinander anzusteuern
wo sollen die herkommen wie kriegt man
die vom gehirn in die hand das ist
momentan einer der größten
herausforderungen generell so in diesem
bereich klinik und es zeigt uns
natürlich auch das wunder dass ich jetzt
hier gleichsam spielend vollziehe was
unser gehirn in diesem bereich
tatsächlich leistet von dem wir noch
nicht klar verstehen wie das überhaupt
funktioniert wir haben schon ziemlich
gutes verständnis wir wollen wie das
funktioniert gerade auch die hand im
motorischen kortex abgebildet ist wieder
die verschaltung sind über die
verschiedene nerven
aber das problem ist sie haben mal einen
richtig großen nervst der in den arm
läuft und der sich erst sehr spät
verästelt und sie können sie kommen an
diesen nerv vor der festung nur ganz
ganz schwierig an das ist ganz schwierig
da sozusagen die einzelnen kanäle drin
zu finden und selbst wenn sie das finden
wir schließen sie dann kabel an wie soll
das gehen von der hautoberfläche kommen
sie nicht an die auflösung ist viel zu
schlecht sie müssten vielleicht dann in
den körper rein gehen aber dann sind wir
dann schon in den bereich müssen wir
wirklich irgendwie in die leute
aufschneiden damit meine prothese
bedienen kann und die ist es nun direkt
im gehirn anzusetzen er aber im ernst
soll ich mich jetzt einer hirn operation
unterziehen wo mir die schädeldecke auf
gesicht wird mit eventuell großen
risiken und komplikationen das sind auch
risiken die man abwägen muss wo ich
alles andere als ein gutes gefühl bei
haben wir haben ja den begriff des
cyborgs eingeführt die reingekommen
begriff ausreicht das science fiction
ist aber natürlich trifft ja auch so
sagen beschreibt der ganz konkret was
bei ihnen der fall ist eine fast
organischen verschmelzung von technik
und leid von mensch und maschine
würden sie sich selbst als cyborg
bezeichnen oder bezeichnen wollen nein
ich kann mit dem begriff nur ganz wenig
anfangen
gar nicht so sehr auf grund seiner
herkunft
ursprünglich kommt der der begriff
cyborg aus den 60er jahren als
kybernetische organismus und war auch
ursprünglich gedacht für einen
organismus dessen biologie so verändert
wurde dass er sich widrigen
lebensumständen anpassen kann die ersten
zwei blocks von denen auch in der
wissenschaft literatur in den 60er
jahren so in der kybernetik die rede war
waren organismen wo zum beispiel kein
blut und kein sauerstoff nötig ist um
den organismus am laufen zu halten
sondern vielleicht methan oder dass man
auch mal angehen
der begriff hat danach eine wandlung
erlebt und bezeichnet eben jetzt ich
würde mal sagen so alltag sprachlich
wenn wir so eine mischung aus mensch und
maschine
aber so wie der verwendet wird und auch
sowie ein ideal konnotiert ist ist das
finde ich auch was negativ da schwingt
immer auch so eine bedrohung mit servo
andenken denn die leute wenn man cyborg
sagt ja dann die burg aus raumschiff
enterprise
widerstand ist zwecklos ja da ist der
terminator und so weiter und so weiter
und das ist eine seiner inthronisierung
durch den begriff würden sie sagen jaja
oder zumindest ja also inthronisierung
sie können das so nennen ich für mich
hat er für mich springt schwingt bei
diesem begriff immer so etwas kaltes
bedrohliches mit und so sehe ich mich
nicht und deswegen kann ich diesen
begriff nicht an
es ist ja so lebensweltlich gibt es ja
sehr viel mehr menschen die mit
implantaten und technischen prothesen
leben als wir so wahrnehmen da könnt ihr
sagen die insulinpumpe ein
herzschrittmacher eine brille die
natürlich jetzt nicht ganz organisch
angewachsen ist aber das könnte man das
könnte man machen also wie viel prozent
denken sie denn der bevölkerung lebt
eigentlich mit ganz organisch mit
prothetischen oder technischen
hilfsmittel die an den leib
angeschlossen
ich kenne daher keine zahlen so aber ich
glaube es ist mehr als wir denken
einfach weil viele dieser hilfsmittel ja
gar nicht sichtbar sind überlegen sie
mal wie viele leute mit einem
künstlichen kniegelenk oder einen
künstlichen hüftgelenken unterwegs sind
auch das ist ja schon biologisch
angepasste technik die noch nicht auf
eine ganz andere art und weise mit dem
körper verschmolzen fest dass sie ich
kenne die prothese abends abnehmen aber
künstliches kniegelenk wird er richtig
in den knochen eingefräst jetzt wollen
wir uns etwas anschauen denn am 8
oktober fand in zürich von der eth von
der eidgenössisch technischen hochschule
der erste cybertron stadt ein wettkampf
von menschen die mit assistenz
technologien leben diese zum einsatz
bringen unter sportlichen bedingungen da
wurden ganz verschiedene
leistungsschauen und tests durchgeführt
und schauen wir doch mal den trailer
dieses heimatland vom 8 oktober dieses
jahres an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sind beeindruckende bilder
beeindruckende leistung und falls sie
den cybertron verpasst haben sollten
gestern können sie jetzt die highlights
auf unserer website nachschauen
zudem finden sie dort viele interessante
sendungen die im rahmen der sft woche
mensch-maschine ausgestrahlt wurden
naja diese leistungsschau der traum
eines sportlichen gewandes wie
beurteilen sie als sozialpsychologe
trägt das zur normalisierung dieser
menschen bei das ist eine schwierige
frage die sich heute noch sehr schwer
beantworten lässt denn die technologie
auch die wir gerade dem trailer gesehen
haben hat ja erst mal ein großes
potenzial
nämlich die beeinträchtigung die mit
einer körperbehinderung einhergeht
zudem will ihren weg zu nehmen
und deswegen finde ich es auch völlig in
ordnung und auch spannend sich
anzuschauen wie gut dass heute
heutzutage schon geht wie gut wir die
beeinträchtigungen überwinden können und
das in einem sportlichen fröhlichen
kontext zu tun das will ich nicht ganz
schön
der ist heilbronn hat jetzt zum ersten
mal stattgefunden und da gibt es
natürlich auch ein großes potenzial für
die zukunft ausverkauftem haus ein
riesiges mediales und auch
publikumsinteresse großartig großartig
der große unterschied zwischen den
paralympics und dem cybertron ist ja
dass bei den paralympics keine prothesen
und hilfsmittel verwendet werden dürfen
die eine energiequelle in irgendeiner
form haben das dürfte nur mechanische
geräte sein wo alle energie die hinein
kommt vom körper des trägers hineinkommt
der cybertron hat diese grenze nicht da
haben wir also ein wettkampf wo
technologie am körper ist die elektrisch
angetrieben ist und ich denke was ihnen
aus zum hirn übrigens es gibt ja
menschen dort die vom hals wirbel
abgelehnt sind und mit gedankenkraft zum
beispiel computerspiele vollziehen also
das ist glaube ich dass das extremste
und auch eines der faszinierenden
beispiel beziehungsweise disziplinen
aber gerade wenn wir jetzt mal so bei
den disziplinen
die prothesen rennen also mit
beinprothese bleiben da haben wir dann
hier auch teilnehmer den beiden
paralympics nicht starten dürfen weil
sie zum beispiel ein kniegelenk haben wo
ein elektrischer motor und ein großer
akku drin wie das man auch gerade im
trailer gesehen hat keiner dieser
athleten oder piloten wie es
korrekterweise beim cyber zu sein
wer hat superkräfte damit ja noch nicht
aber wer weiß wenn wir das jetzt jedes
jahr veranstalten vielleicht in 20 30
jahren uns nochmal hier unterhalten ob
wir dann athleten haben die durch diese
kombination von körper mit maschine
leistungen eventuell erzielen können
die über dem liegen was ein
nichtbehinderter körper in der lage wäre
zu leisten dazu kommen wir auch noch
gleich
zunächst ist ja auch mal so dass gerade
hier in der schweiz gesamten forschungs
und innovationsprojekte im themenjahr
robot liegt an der eth zürich in
lausanne an der eps sie waren ja auch
lange als wissenschaftler in zürich
aktiv waren sie eingebunden als
psychologe in diese entwicklung ein
kleines bisschen aber mehr noch als
versuchskaninchen und zwar auch an der
uni zürich wo ich sieben jahre lang
gearbeitet habe er gibt es ein großes
labor für künstliche intelligenz und
robotik da experimentiert man vor allen
dingen im leben bereich des embodiment
also dass man versucht auch so
eigenschaften des körpers und der
biologie so in die robotik
hineinzubringen ganz faszinierend da gab
es dann auch versuche man daran
gearbeitet hat auch haptik zum beispiel
also eine reine eine sensibilität für
für für griff und gefühl also passt sind
in prothetik engen zu implementieren und
da hatte ich das große verlierer ein
bisschen mitzuwirken sowohl
konzeptionellen info zu leisten aber
mich auch ganz trivial als
versuchspersonen zu verwenden wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe ist da noch
eine eine weiter weg zu beschreiten dass
man zum beispiel samt von cord oder von
einer fliese oder von wasser unterspült
mit dem gespür ja aber dafür bräuchten
wir ein interface das nicht nur in der
lage ist vom nerv an die prothese zu
kommunizieren sondern auch noch zurück
ja von der prothese an den nerven
da kann man auch drumherum arbeiten
indem man zum beispiel durch vibrationen
am armstumpf versucht zu symbolisieren
wenn sie so wollen dass man etwas
berührt und sozusagen sonne sonne sonne
interpretation dann selber vornehmen
muss und das automatisiert dann mit der
zeit auch aber das ist noch sehr weit
weg von mit einer prothese würde ich was
tasten zu also dass viele helfen und das
fühlen dass sie nochmal zwei ganz
verschiedene dinge
ist es denn eigentlich und sie
besprachen wir schon sagen der ist der
sport so eine art laboratorium des
leibes ist in die zukunft des leides
sich zeigt ist dass wir sie dann auch
kein zufall dass sich der cybertron das
gewand eines sportlichen wettkampfes
gibt nein das ist für mich kein zufall
denn in einem sportlichen wettkampf geht
es ja auch immer darum fähigkeiten
kompetenzen zu demonstrieren und ob
jemand kompetent ist oder inkompetent in
seinem ganz allgemein formulierten sinne
ist eine der zwei grund dimensionen von
stereotypen also stereotypen sagen immer
etwas darüber aus ob ein mensch der zu
einer gruppe gehört die mit einem
stereotyp versehen sind
ob dieser mensch kompetent oder
inkompetent ist und ob er gute absichten
oder eher schlecht dass die wärme
dimension war munter absichten kalt
schädliche absichten und ob er dann
diese absichten auch in die tat umsetzen
kann das ist die kompetenz dimension und
wo kann man kompetenz gar körperliche
kompetenz besser zeigen als im wettkampf
als im sport zumal ja sagen behinderte
menschen leicht in den stereotyp des
inkompetenten fallen oder gelangen da
gibt es sogar ein bisschen untersuchen
zu können das ganz eindeutig zeigen auch
gerade in für den deutschsprachigen raum
mein kollege frank asbeck hat dazu einen
artikel veröffentlicht schon 2015 oder
wo er zeigt dass allgemein dass die
youtube gegenüber menschen mit
körperbehinderung bedeutet warm aber
inkompetenten also im sinne von
sympathisch aber nicht hinaus jetzt
wollen wir mal zeigen sie sprachen das
ja schon an dass durch diese
eigenantrieb auch dinge möglich sind die
unser sogenannten normaler körper nicht
kann und eines davon kann er einnimmt
auch das ist besonders beeindruckend uns
vielleicht mal kurz zeigen das ist
nämlich sozusagen der schrauben trebs
schauen sie erträglich sagt ich sage
eigentlich immer so ein bisschen auf der
party trägt dazu bei
weil also so nützlich ist es jetzt auch
gar nicht unbedingt aber sind anhalt das
handgelenk und 360 grad drehen
stufenlos das heißt wenn sie es
hinbekommen den schraubenzieher so zu
halten was ist es das vielleicht ein
bisschen obszön aus aber wenn sie es
hinkriegen den schraubenzieher so zu
halten dass er in der verlängerung der
achse des handgelenkes liegt dann können
sie tatsächlich musste so ein bisschen
ausgleichen aber dann kriegen sie
tatsächlich können sie tatsächlich ein
schraubendreher und 360° wenn man das
noch ein bisschen vereinfacht wird das
vielleicht für einige anfällig da steckt
natürlich jetzt eine große faszination
auch eine gewisse komik kann man sagen
aber es steckt auch eine ernste frage
die sie bereits angesprochen haben was
passiert wenn diese prothesen dinge
vollziehen können die wir mit dem
normalen körper sonst nicht vollziehen
können dass ich eine frage die sich im
sport und gerade bei den paralympics in
besonderer weise stellt zum beispiel bei
sportlern wie oscar pistorius der dass
ihr ein besonders gutes beispiel ist den
wir hier sehen
1 1 400 meter hürden sprinter der auch
an den olympischen spielen teilgenommen
hat und auf dem endlauf war
und da war immer die frage ob diese
prothesen ihm einen wettbewerbsvorteil
verschaffen was ich in der debatte um
historisch spannend fand also dann auch
vor allem in der zeit bevor er seine
freundin erschossen hat war dass der
begriff techno doping genau und auch in
der englischen presse die frage gestellt
wurde ob er einen an verwandte hat also
einen unfairen vorteil
das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen einen unfairen vorteil
weil ihn zwei füße fehlen
das ist ja schon erstmal eine internet
die entwicklung die noch vor wenigen
jahren gar nicht absehbar war dass man
ernsthaft sportlern denen körperteile
fehlen unterstellt sie hätten dadurch
einen unfairen vorteil weil das fehlen
des körperteils platz macht für ein
hilfsmittel das im verdacht steht
übermenschliche fähigkeiten zu verleihen
jetzt hier die variabilität und das
wippen der prothesen soll angeblich eine
bessere federung für das laufen und
dadurch geschwindigkeit steigern seien
richtig und soweit ich die
biomechanischen befunde kennen
verbraucht ein läufer oscar pistorius
mit solchen carbon federn auch 30
prozent weniger sauerstoff als ein
nichtbehinderter auf gleicher strecke
geschenke nicht durchblutet genau aber
hat aber auf der anderen seite auch
muskel skelett eher nachteile also man
muss immer das gesamtsystem zu
betrachten und im fall von pistorius
wurde er im einzelfall entschieden dass
er starten kann weil er als gesamtsystem
ja der körper mit diesen prothesen ja
nicht bevorteilt ist aber die potters
potenzial ist hier dass ich einen
interessanteren fall finde ist markus
rehm ja ja dann hat er ja auch jede weit
springer der nicht zugelassen wurde
jetzt ja nicht zugelassen wurde
ich finde er macht das medial ganz
beeindruckend da macht da keine große
sache draus und er hat glaube ich die
entscheidung auch akzeptiert für sich
ich finde er hat da einen sehr
entspannten unaufgeregten umgang mit
dass das finde ich sehr bewundernswert
was ich bei rim noch anders als
pistorius springt er redet mit seiner
prothese weiter als nicht behinderte
athleten tatsächlich pistorius ist nie
so schnell die 400 meter gelaufen wie
nicht behinderte athleten gehen springt
aber weiter als nichtbehinderte abnehmen
meines wissens hält er auch den oberen
modem bei sprung deswegen ist leben
eigentlich finde ich noch das bessere
beispiel als boris pistorius weil er
zeigt das ist eventuell möglich sein
könnte prothesen zu haben die zumindest
für bestimmte anwendungskontext einen
vorteil bieten der über die fähigkeiten
des nichtbehinderten körpers
lancom fairness erwägungen ins spiel
nicht nur im sport sondern man könnte ja
auch sagen das ist mal ganz platt es
könnte auch ein handwerker geben der
sagen würde ich muss den ganzen tag
schrauben für mich ist das einfach
besser im alltag und dann könnte man
sich denken ich entscheide mich dazu wir
vielleicht prothetische etwas selbst an
schrauben zu lassen ganz einfach weil
das im alltag hilft das sind natürlich
szenarien die wir aus science fiction
filmen kennen aber sie scheinen ja
lebensweltlich nicht vollends
unplausibel also sicherlich verletzt und
plausibel aber ich denke da muss man
auch realistisch sei nicht oder ich
finde da müssen wir auch im medialen des
großen bisschen vorsichtig sein
es stellt sich auch gerade auch durch
vielleicht durch solche gespräche wählen
wie sie führen und die beispiele die wir
gesehen haben häufig so dar als seien
wir schon so weit als hätten prothesen
superkräften haben sie nicht haben sie
nicht haben sie nicht und ich kann damit
nicht klavier spielen ja und herren
kommt auch im alltag mit dieser kampagne
feder sicherlich nicht so gut zurecht
wie jemand der beide wann hat also schon
das muss man erst mal klar feststellen
deswegen ist der techno doping begriff
auch hatte kalibriert ein bisschen
unfair finde ich auch also der und ich
finde das muss man auch im medialen
diskurs muss man denke auch mal ein
bisschen mehr realismus 1 1 verlassen
aber sie haben natürlich recht
es erscheint plausibel in einer meiner
meinung nach sehr sehr fernen zukunft
wahrscheinlich außerhalb unserer beider
lebensspanne so ob sie sich technik an
den körper schrauben oder nicht kann man
ja sagen durch das ist im duell mit zwei
und zwar individuell entscheidung aber
um sich solche technik an den körper zu
schrauben muss erstmal was fehlenden
da muss er platz für sein doch wenn sie
sehen was leute mit
schönheitsoperationen für schmerzen für
entbehrungen in kauf nehmen um einen
größeren hintern zu haben oder dickere
lippen scheint das ja jetzt sagen die
menschen tun so heißt es ist denke ich
nicht theoretisch vollkommen
ausgeschlossen dass man gewinnt das
beispiel schönheitsindustrie oder
schönheitschirurgie ist ein sehr gutes
beispiel oder mögliches parallel
beispiel bei der schönheitschirurgie
geht es um eine ästhetische
verbesserungen des körpers und ich denke
man muss sich klarmachen es gibt ja auch
leute die durch krankheit oder unfall
oder missbildung wirklich entstellt sind
und wo es kein ganz offensichtlichen
medizinischen nutzen gibt aber natürlich
gibt es auch viele fälle wo das einfach
ein eigenes eine ästhetisch nichts
weiter als ein ästhetisches bedürfnis
der mensch des menschen ist der sich
einer solchen der sich an solchen
eingriff unterzieht
und warum sollte das nur auf ästhetische
besserungen beschränkt bleiben und sich
nicht auch auf funktionale
verbesserungen ausweiten lassen aber die
frage ist darf man das als arzt darf man
ein gesundes körperteil empfehlen
entschädigung oder entfernen um den
anschluss an platz zu schaffen für ein
technisches körperteil das eventuell
besser ist und ich denke von
bürokratischen eines nicht gedeckt aber
ich denke da hat bewegt sich auch die
schönheitschirurgie teilweise in einer
grauzone die da genutzt wird und das
wird vielleicht dort umgang ist also das
stichwort oder gar große thema dahinter
sich trans humanismus ja wir leben in
einer zeit in der nicht nur durch
prothesen sondern auch über genetische
ermöglicht die manipulation das bild
dessen was der mensch ist als leib einer
starken veränderung und auch optimierung
unterliegen könnte und sie sagen jetzt
wir müssen einfach ethisch darüber
nachdenken wo die grenzen sind
wer soll denn da grenzen setzen und
fragt sie mal zwei drei alternativen
sollen wir uns eine göttliche gesetze
halten an menschliche gesetze oder
einfach nur an das was verantwortlich
umsetzbar ist
ich habe keine einfache antwort traurig
als wissenschaftler habe ich mit den
örtlichen gesetzen so ein bisschen meine
probleme
ich denke was ich mir wünsche wäre er
zunächst mal eine etwas breitere
öffentliche medialer diskurs um darüber
nachzudenken die wollen wir unsere
gesellschaft in zukunft gestalten
wie wollen wir mit möglichkeiten die
sich in der zukunft bieten um gehen
bevor es soweit ist dass nur noch die
ingenieure und die betriebswirte darüber
zu entscheiden haben denn wir sprechen
hier ja auch über große potenzielle
märkte dann überlegen sie mal eine hand
wie diese ist natürlich ein nischen
produkt die hat ja einen therapeutischen
zweck meine fähigkeit sind unterhalb der
norm und ich verwende den begriff norm
als einen statistischen begriff so ein
der den durchschnitt der bevölkerung
beschreiben ja so verwende ich den gar
nicht normativ im handel von natürlich
sondern als stadt ist was man halt so
kann was was durch also in der
durchschnitt ist ja sagen wir mal
durchschnitt plus - ein standard
abwehren so wenn der durchschnitt ist
man also der durchschnitt ist
wahrscheinlich so 9 finger ab will ich
mal so tippen gibt viele menschen geben
die vielleicht auch manche haben also
der durch ist wahrscheinlich neun finger
ich hab nur 5 und dann sagt man okay man
bringt durch einen therapeuten eingriff
den menschen in richtung des
durchschnitts und ich bin aber immer
noch unterdurchschnittlich ich kann
immer noch nicht glauben spielen so und
in dem moment wo ich jetzt anfangen über
den durchschnitt zu gehen also aus dem
neuen bereich zu verändern aber nicht
aber eben aus der norm weg in richtung
überkapazitäten dann fangen wir an über
den händen und trans am und im sinne von
verbesserung genau also vorher sprechen
wir von therapie und danach von
enhancement insel von verbesserungen das
problem ist aber ja bei dieser
definition dass beides sowohl die
therapie also in hammond von einer
statistischen norm nämlich dem
durchschnitt abhängig ist aber wenn
jetzt immer mehr menschen sich in
irgendeiner form verbessern dann
verschiebt sich natürlich auch mehr der
durch dna das heißt wenn wir alle eine
laser augen korrektur uns unterziehen
lassen wenn wir in die pubertät kommen
die aus 120 prozent sehvermögen beschert
und wenn das alle in der gesellschaft
machen dann sind natürlich die mit 80
prozent sehvermögen die früher noch im
normbereich lagen auf einmal unser auf
die sehen ja und das finde ich ihn
fasziniere gedanken seiner
abschließenden horizont des menschlichen
dieser normalität fließt mit der zeit
sie verändert sich und jetzt mal ganz
konkret wenn ein junger pilot werden
will dann braucht er vielleicht in
zukunft die 120 prozent allein netzhaut
chip ermöglicht und dann würden wir
sagen na ja es ist vielleicht nicht
normal im sinne von natürlich aber es
ist das was man heutzutage kann jedoch
jaja da kommen natürlich auch ganz
andere überlegungen zum beispiel ihr
einen wenn ich es richtig hier ist etwa
bei 60.000 euro als als kosten nicht
ganz also da muss man ein bisschen
differenzieren also zwischen der hand
und dem schafft er noch individuell
angefertigt sowie das hier im ganzen ist
liegt man sogar um die 50.000 genau und
das wird ja nicht von der kasse bezahlt
doch als dieses produkt aber sicher aber
na also aber sicher mit sternchen
gerade in der bundesrepublik sind die
kassen gibt es inzwischen gesetze
urteile die ganz klar sagen das ist ein
zweckmäßiges hilfsmittel was von den
kassen übernommen werden muss gibt es
präsident werde landessozialgerichte
haben so entschieden
kassen hassen ist das heißt wenn man als
betroffene person einen antrag auf eine
kostenübernahme für eine solche heizung
prothese stellt dann heißt es erstmal
nein gibt es nicht und dann muss man
sich auf die hinterbeine stellen ich
habe mir meine erste eilen die
allererste hiervon hier habe ich mir
nicht an sponsoren vertrag finanziert
dann legt sich noch in der schweiz die
habe ich mir in einer langen
auseinandersetzung von der iv erstritten
von der iv und das war sehr sehr
unangenehm ist nein kommt nicht in frage
sie kriegen nur die billige version mit
der habe ich aber jetzt schon probleme
mit der schulter ich und so weiter ich
muss jetzt nicht so ins detail gehen das
führte aber dazu dass die mir zwei
gutachter geschickt haben die mich in
halben tag mit einem klemmbrett unter
dem arm begleitet haben ohne witz und so
geguckt haben ob der mann wirklich 10
funktionierende finger braucht oder ob
die lenkung grafische drangsalierung um
diese kosten verstanden jemand das will
man das ja auch erwarten würde gibt es
sehr unangenehm aber es würde natürlich
also in einer perspektive auf auf die
westliche welt bedeuten dass es langsam
oder absehbar etwas kosten könnte ein
normaler mensch zu sein
das heißt dass diese verbesserungen
schneider standard werden und dann
kommen ja diejenigen die vielleicht
weniger geld haben nicht nur dadurch
dass sie ohnehin schon sozial
benachteiligt sind sondern auch ein
leistungsmäßig in ein hintertreffen
ich sehe das genauso aber was ich dazu
sagen muss ist das ist ja nichts neues
die welt funktioniert auch heute schon
genauso und sie sprechen ja über eine
welt in der die finanziellen materiellen
möglichkeiten eines menschen wenn es
eine ein hands sind industrie gäbe die
möglichkeit geben würden noch mehr
soziale ungleichheiten zu zu potenzieren
ja weil so sagen dann das ist ja auch so
diese idee dass es dann eine elite gibt
die zugang zu dieser technologie
aber seien wir doch mal ehrlich das ist
doch heute schon sohn ja wer wer zugang
zu vielen materiellen ressourcen hat
kann sich selber und von mir als auch
die kinder optimieren jan durch
gesündere ernährung sport eine bessere
bildung es ist doch alles nichts neues
dass
das multipliziert oder verstärkt oder
genauso wie das ist noch ein
potenzieller multiplikator der denke ich
er dazu beitragen wird dass sich
ungleichheit noch potenzieren und
verstärkt auch so jetzt reden wir
natürlich über diese sachen so
alteuropäischen möchte ich sagen dass
ethische bedenken gebe es probleme es
gibt andrea privilegierten perspektive
gibt einen anderen erdteil der nennen
wir jetzt mal kalifornien indem man sagt
lass uns doch mal mit der ethik in ruhe
lasst uns erst mal begeistert sein was
passiert was möglich ist würden sie denn
sagen dass der st der geist der
innovation in europa dadurch begrenzt
wird dass wir immer gleich das ethische
mitdenken ich das sehe ich überhaupt
nichts und risse also dass ich werde
glaubt ein zentrales beispiel ist ist
ist meine allem die kommt von einem
kleinen start up aus schottland ja da
hat sich ein kleines team aus gegründet
aus dem staatlichen gesundheitssystem
großbritanniens waren ursprünglich war
das ein spin off von jackson also vom
national health genau während von der so
was wie die iv her wie hier
daraus hat sich das gegründet und die
haben mit dieser innovation es war die
erste firma die eine handprothese auf
den markt gebracht hat die voll
artikulieren ist beantworten wo die
finger sich einzeln bewegen können und
einzeln angesteuert sind das dachte man
vor das geht gar nicht weil nicht genug
platz ist in der handel und die haben
damit den markt komplett
durcheinandergewirbelt und auch den
marktführer vom thron gestoßen das ist
ne das ist doch ein gutes beispiel für
eine innovation auch aus europa ist das
business system youtube so dass die
amerikaner die ethischen bedenken über
bord werfen
das tun sie um glaube ich auch nicht ich
glaube auch man muss nicht ethische
bedenken
so haben dass sie da durch innovation
begrenzen das eine ist die entwicklung
von technologie technologie ist meiner
festen überzeugung nach vor sich nicht
bösesten die nutzung entscheidet ob die
technologie gut oder böse sehen ich
finde da kann man mit einem
gesellschaftlichen diskurs sich
überlegen und steuernd eingreifen und
ich finde es richtig und wichtig und ich
bin nicht der meinung dass das unsere
innovativität in europa ins
hintertreffen
das ist glaube ich ganz ganz
nachvollziehbare appell zu sagen dass
die ethik nicht als etwas fremdes und
etwas integriertes an diese entwicklung
mehr zu sagen wir können natürlich zb
uns auch andere ethische fragen
wenn ich jetzt mit ihrer app ihrer hand
steuern und sie tun dann mit dieser hand
etwas was ich eigentlich getan habe dann
ist ja zum beispiel die frage wer
handelt da das mag jetzt in dieser
situation nicht problematisch seien und
man kann sich ja einen cyber soldier
vorstellen der ferngesteuert von einem
kommandozentrum mit gewissen prothesen
dinge tut die er dann selbst gar nicht
getan hat ja eine solche zukunft ist
denkbar
und das sind fragen nach
verantwortungsvollem handeln
die wir uns generell stellen müssen in
einer zukunft wo wir auch immer mehr
künstliche intelligenz haben werden und
ich glaube wenn sie sich anschauen wie
schwierig das jetzt alleine schon ist
jede gerichtlichen hin zu entwickeln für
autonomes fahren die entscheidung die
die autos treffen müssen wenn es
vielleicht in seltenen extremsituationen
um leben und tod geht an einer sich da
schon gedanken so was sie machen das
sind ja jetzt schon kommission bei der
arbeit die auch noch keine eindeutigen
antworten dafür vorgelegt haben und ich
glaube was sagt ihr zum beispiel ihre
intuition wenn ich jetzt auf den knopf
drücken und ihre hand bewegt sich handle
ich dann eher sagen wir die technik oder
sie an sie handeln und ich denke das
muss man einfach systemisch denken also
ich denke da muss man auch den handlungs
und den verantwortungs begriff so
erweitern dass es nicht mehr nur das
unmittelbare körperliche ist das ist
jetzt natürlich noch ein sehr schönes
beispiel die hand öffnen schließen macht
immer noch ich sie steuern nur die geste
und ich kann sie auch ausmachen
da gibt's auch ein passwort und also wer
aber könnte auch gehackt werden könnte
auch können auch könnte auch gehackt
werden und deswegen glaube ich es
braucht auch immer noch eine andere
debatte zum thema sicherheit und
datenschutz
die wir führen müssen wenn mehr technik
unter die haut gehen
der
amerikaner mark und man hat ein buch
geschrieben future krems wo es darum
geht welche neuen hacker möglichkeiten
sich ergeben durch diese technologie und
ich bin das krasseste beispiel als er
dort beschrieben hat war es gibt eine
bestimmte art von insulinpumpe den
menschen mit einer bestimmten mit einem
bestimmten typ diabetes kann direkt am
körper tragen gibt es fest angeschlossen
ist mit dem blutkreislauf und es gab
schon jemanden das war nicht mal
spinnerei der ein bluetooth gerät
entwickelt hat mit dem ziel diese dinge
dazu zu kriegen eine tödliche indonesien
zurück insulin großes abzugeben das
heißt wir kommen kommen vielleicht
perspektivische nein zeit heide wo sich
jemand mit dem heck töten können und ich
glaube dass unsere heutigen vorstellung
von sicherheit und privatsphäre nicht
dazu geeignet sind und mit solchen
bedrohung umzugehen
sie sprachen gerade von effekten die
unter die haut gehen nicht nur technisch
sondern auch metaphorisch sie haben
selber an ein projekt mitgearbeitet dem
sogenannten bionic men dass ihnen bin
ich das richtig gesehen habe extrem
unter die haut ging es war ein mensch
der nur aus prothetischen ersatzteilen
oder teilen besteht und der ihr gesicht
trug und es gibt dazu einen
dokumentarfilm da ist bionic men und in
dem moment in dem sie diesen dieses
wesen sehen dass ihr gesicht trägt da
sind sie erschüttert passiert etwas ganz
besonderes da wollen wir sprechen
es waren von anfang an eigentlich nicht
abgesprochen dass ein silikon replikat
meines gesichtes auf dieses ding drauf
kommt das hat sich so im laufe der
produktion als möglichkeit ergeben
und jetzt haben sie da dieses alles
andere als ästhetisch aussehen gewesen
wo jetzt so eine gummi version von ihrem
gesicht drauf ist und es sieht fast so
aus wie das was sie sehen wenn sie in
den spiegel schauen aber es ist ein
kleines stück daneben und das ist
eigentlich unheimlich also sie gucken so
eine situation ist oder so eine komische
künstlich leicht verzerrte version von
sich selber an
er hat das als extrem unangenehm
empfunden also richtig war richtig
angeekelt ich muss auch ein bisschen
szene machen und mit türenknallen aus
dem raum laufen weil ich das gar nicht
cool fand war das vielleicht auch so
frank und strömungen sowie sagen wir tun
hier etwas das vielleicht ganz
gefährlich sah das will ich ein bisschen
überzeichnet denn die freyenstein das
ist ja neues leben und so mal was haben
wir da gemacht oder haben auf der welt
die damals ist ja schon 2013 ausgestellt
worden verfügbaren ersatzteile
zusammengesucht und haben die angeschaut
was die können und haben die
zusammengefügt auf einem rahmen um mal
zu gucken wenn man alles zusammen bringt
was ist schon so gibt was kommt dabei
raus und das war hier frank oder alles
andere als zukunftsweisendes hightech
mäßig rüber kam aber es gibt eine
übergangs gestalt zwischen diesen bionic
men und frankenstein der auch sang
kulturell ganz tief verankert wird mich
bei metropolis die sogenannte olympia
wenn sie die erkennen das ist eine frau
die verstorben ist und dann von einem
genialen erfinder neu erschaffen wird
weil er diese frau nicht verlieren
da sehen sie das ist fast ein bajonett
men wenn sie so wollen
aber es ist eben auch mit dem ziel getan
sterblichkeit endlichkeit zu bekämpfen
das ist ja auch etwas was immer
mitschwingt in diesen typen also ich
würde sagen es ist der das extremste
ziel der menschen die sich diesen diesen
ein hands nennt verschrieben haben
das ultimative enhancement ist ja den
tod zu besiegen
deswegen gibt es auch befürworter von
unsterblichkeit und technologien die es
ermöglichen in dieser ein hands sind als
jene einige sehr populäre auch sehr
polarisierende figuren ich das sind
alles sehr privilegierte weiße männer
die häufig ein argument anführen wie es
wäre schade wenn all das wissen was man
ich denke dann immer klammer auf ich
klammer zu mir im leben erworben habe
wenn das einfach verloren geht ja und
dann müsste man doch irgendwie was tun
im grunde genommen ist es doch das
hadern irgendwie mit dem eigenen ende
und dass man versucht eine technische
lösung zu finden ich meine ganz
persönliche meinung das ist jetzt
sicherlich nicht besonders philosophisch
fungiert ist ich finde das auge und ich
finde sie ich finde es unfassbar
anmaßung siehst du hast nicht
rassistisch sagt so gerade gerade wäre
doch schade wenn du mich ja wäre doch
schade ja und deswegen müssen wir doch
irgendwie außerdem glaube ich und da
kann man denke ich auch noch
dieses argument bringen ein zentraler
mechanismus für die weiterentwicklung
und auch die evolution unserer spezies
variation selektion retention ein
zentraler mechanismus biologische
evolution funktioniert so evolution von
ideen und wissensproduktion funktioniert
so es muss eine variabilität von
möglichkeiten geben da muss es ein wie
auch immer geartetes und vielleicht eher
zufälligen selektionsprozess geben der
auf die zufällige variabilität irgendwie
aufsetzt und dann muss ich irgendwie was
durchsetzen
greifen wir nicht wenn wir anfangen
menschen unsterblich zu machen in diesem
in diesen mechanismus anja nämlich ist
nicht das sterben auch ein wichtiger
teil dieses variationen selektions
retentionsflächen das muss ich kann das
nicht beurteilen da könnt ihr sagen
dadurch dass man mehrere technische
möglichkeiten schafft öffnet man einen
weiteren selektions raum gleich dass da
durchaus ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht
dass der mensch in der lage ist die
komplexität gerade von so spezies ebenen
entwicklungsprozessen zu durchdringen zu
verstehen das eingreifen in selbiges auf
einer spezies ebene zu positiven
konsequenzen führt der mensch ist
notorisch schlechte rennen komplexe
systeme zu bringen und zu uns und
positiv zu beeinflussen da gibt es
tausende bayerischen in der
menschheitsgeschichte also das würden
wir uns im sinne von pro metrische
gelöst hat auch überheben derzeit meiste
ist ist natürlich ein bisschen meine
befürchtung aber man muss natürlich das
konterkarieren mit auch einer ethischen
positionen ja jedes leben des lebens
wert darf man sagen okay wir setzen
alles daran um ein leben zu erhalten
wenn jemand erkrankt ein unfall hat
irgendwie sonst medizinisch aber ab 80
90 sagen wir ab hier geht es nicht mehr
ja also wenn wir sozusagen so diese
diesen ethischen imperativ haben dass
jedes leben jedes leben schützenswert
ist kann man es an eigentlich ethisch
vertreten nicht an der unsterblichkeit
also ist die unsterblichkeit nicht
eigentlich eine logische kandidat in
pará tief unseres handelns
ich glaube das ist das ist so eine
komplette komplizierte logistik und jagd
haben ja fast ein schauer über den
rücken wenn man so etwas wenn man so
etwas sagt ich will ja noch was jetzt
alles passt ganz interessant war was sie
sagen es geht ja auch um endlichkeit und
begrenzungen zu akzeptieren und
natürlich könnte man sagen prothesen die
ihre haben einen sehr positiven effekt
aber sie verhindern auch prozesse auch
bei behinderten menschen mit dem was man
isst akzeptieren umzugehen das heißt
sich selbst als der anzunehmen der mann
ist sehen sie da eine dialekte zwischen
techniker optimierung und streicht den
verlust einer gesellschaft einfach auch
mit begrenzungen produktiver umzugehen
das ist eine gute frage ich mache mir in
der tat ein bisschen sorgen dass wir
jetzt denken eine technologische
innovation wie in der prothetik wird
eine soziale herausforderung nämlich den
umgang mit andersartigkeit mit mitleid
auch mit behinderung wird das irgendwie
lösen aber das sollte es macht ja die
behinderung die behinderung verschwindet
durch technik das tut es natürlich nicht
sondern technik hilft uns bestimmte
einschränkungen zu überwinden und das
finde ich auch gut aber es hat natürlich
auch die gefahr so ein bisschen so die
natürliche variabilität denn mein körper
ist ja auch natürlich ich bin zwar
seltener wenn die ausbildung ist es aber
diese seltenheit ist ja natürlich das
ist genau so wie es ist teil des
evolutionsgeschichte dass sie dir ja
erwähnt verändert ja ich habe ich meine
rote haare sind auch seltener als blonde
haare aber sie sind deswegen nicht
weniger natürlich ja also mein körper
ist ja auch natürlich und ich finde das
ziel einer inklusiven gesellschaft muss
sein
jede häufigkeit auch die seltenheit als
natürlich anzuerkennen und meine sorge
ist dass man diese unterschiedlichkeit
versucht technologisch auf ein bisschen
weg zu machen
eine normierung im sinne der im geiste
der technik eine normierung und geist
der technik deswegen habe ich persönlich
eine ganz besondere hochachtung für den
menschen mit einer sichtbaren
körperbehinderung die ich sage es ganz
offen ein größeres selbstbewusstsein als
ich haben und so an
ich brauche für mein selbstbewusstsein
hilft mir so eine prothese nicht ich bin
völlig in ordnung so ich bin ich habe
kein problem das zu zeigen und ich komme
damit klar wie meine umwelt reagiert
gehen sie mal mit einem arm ohne
prothese und kurzem t shirt als junge
erwachsene in clubs oder ins schwimmbad
ja das ist wirklich hart da brauchen sie
schon ein sehr dickes fell und ich habe
eine tiefe bewunderung für die menschen
die ein solches dickes fell haben ich
habe es manchmal nicht dass vielleicht
auch eine mahnung ist kann sagt man
sollte diese technischen innovationen
ernst aber auch erziehungsprozess die es
ermöglichen selbstbewusst ohne diese
technischen hilfsmittel das leben zu
gehen dass man den gleicher weise
fördert ich bin der festen überzeugung
dass technische innovationen die
gesellschaftlichen herausforderungen
nicht lösen werden sondern sie können
beitrag dafür behindert auch nicht
behindert wenn er den technischen
innovationen werden behinderungen nicht
verschwinden lassen und schon gar nicht
die herausforderung im umgang mit
behinderung denn diese technischen
innovationen machen ja noch was
sie fokussieren im umgang mit
behinderung auf den beeinträchtigten
körper ein sehr biologistische
medizinisches verständnis von
behinderung ja da ist was mit dem körper
nicht in ordnung deswegen gehen bei den
körper an und versuchen da was zu
verändern
gerade sowohl ich sage jetzt mal
leichtere körperbehinderung wie das mir
ein arm fehlt und ich wurde auch zum
beispiel im rollstuhl sitzen dazu zählen
manifestieren sich ja gerade an der
schnittstelle zwischen dem körper und
der gesellschaft nämlich an der
erwartung der gesellschaft die
gesellschaft erwartet ja vom körper
etwas nämlich zum beispiel dass wir in
der lage sind treppen zu gehen
diese erwartung manifestiert wenn
überall dort wo heute treppen sind
rampen wären wäre im rollstuhl sitzen
auch nicht eine solche behinderung das
heißt umgang mit behinderung passiert
auch immer an der schnittstelle zwischen
körper und gesellschaft und meine sorge
ist dass das ein bisschen aus den fokus
gerät verstehen haben ja nicht alle
zugriffe zu solchen technologien also
wir sehen hier auch dass es zwei
schnittstellen gibt es gibt den
schnittstelle körper und prothese und
gesellschaft und behinderung und die
beiden wollten sich nicht blockieren und
diese gefahr
die gibt es wohl durchaus herr meier ich
danke ihnen sehr für diese stunde
gespräch und auch für das was sie uns
gezeigt haben und zu denken kann
herzlichen dank vielen dank nächste
woche zeigen wir eine wiederholung des
gesprächs mit subject im slowenischen
philosophen der von sich selbst sagt er
sei kein mensch sondern ein monster
barbara bleisch sprach mit ihnen über
ideologie im alltag und über den sex der
zukunft
das sollten sie nicht verpassen und
jetzt gleich sehen sie in der stern
städte musik eine film über maestra der
film porträtiert dirigentin wie etwa die
vaduz engeren silvia caduff und
beleuchtet den langen weg der frauen bis
zum protest bleiben sie also dran und
genießen sie den sonntag auf wiedersehen
[Musik]